hey guys and Dave here we get a couple
videos outside
going on and it shall be there in West
Hollywood in the morning
there's construction there's people
doing landscaping there's burgers
no with a lot of them for you
understand when we do the easy yes we do
everything by ourselves he said
shot by ourselves we set up the audio
hey
tell they think we have a huge oh yeah
long people or ball K updated
who is also the EP for report but also
for the point onto a
network like he's like a jack of all
trades with everything together
yeah like is always the problem solvers
we're looking ahead but
dinner runner yeah I had a right now
this hammer that were done to you
is on the table on a table that I lunch
box that on a book that I
candle literally at that hour gave you
so let's let you looking back I love
this story through the top astronomers
at the SETI Institute which is the third
for extraterrestrial intelligence
University in Berkeley here in
California
they told Congress that we almost a
hundred percent
probability their is extraterrestrial
life
there they were talking more about like
microbial life
not aliens now little green men but
I star and their almost a hundred
percent
30 you decide is the the top people I
know that people don't like that
don't like what they hear resigned his
but I love this because I
a big sigh yeah I and I I V
I believe I don't be you know we've got
before on a major way
you know there is just a little rock and
it's close to
our son Justin up with the right now
with all that
is like year and he's a good Jillian
other stars
those I'll there's so little that we
know about
you know outer space and there's a
little did we know our own ocean
or ocean sessions a so it's kinda
fascinating to know that
like there really is like out there
there's no question about it right
up I don't believe in like the made a
hollywood
alienate people talk about it. there's
like outside on this planet
whenever we talk about stuff like that I
was thinking about how Dennis Kucinich
gotta like crap for saying that he
believes an alien
but me it is that far bashed you know to
think that there's like outside for
there's so little that we understand yet
do you think that even if not a little
green men but we found some sort of
intelligent life somewhere that we can
communicate with
is there any chance we would rather kill
each other I mean if you think that
everything with you on this planet
with people that are beyond our borders
they are bored here
is there any chance that yes I what
would happen would be there to be a
little time
%uh exploration yeah and introspection
about you know like bad and then right
after that it would be that we want what
you have where they want what we had and
it's webber's more
yes Italy they hate us first %uh
I don't yeah I think that people are
naturally afraid when they don't known
what they don't understand people
change don't like taking this strange so
I think it'll probably end up
in a really really bad situation but
nonetheless
I think it's fascinating to know that
there could be like outside of our
planet
and it could be something any
I think about that a forget neither
company that there's a company s
going to senator is trying to send
people off to Mars yeah
and they're doing a one way trip to
one-way trade mark which i think is
but as I would never do that in a
million years I feel like that's the
essence
I'm literally k to get on the road I am
you got a roller coaster but Mr yeah if
I can do that not you know where they
knock you out
you sleep for like 30 years I I really
would
I really lose thirty years of your life
but I guess you sleeping so you know
ages quickly or something anything UK
for my life 000 IU
frugal yeah
story if they think he you looking young
and he
you know that your whatever I i do. I
get here There I it occurred to me
not be so cool older people doing it for
me you
fairest Lord also your loss up
alright with you guys believe in aliens
are we the only ones here
in the universe or is there more less
commish ok
ok